Speaker 1: We now have learned about yet another
fraud perpetrated on you, the American taxpayer,
by Donald Trump and his family. The Washington
Post is now reporting Donald Trump charged the
Secret Service exorbitant rates at his hotels.
This was another grift in order to make money.
Listen to this. Records show that in
40 cases, the Trump Organization billed
the Secret Service far higher amounts than
the approved government rate. In one case,
charging agents 1100 $85 a night to stay
at the Trump International Hotel in D.C..
The new billing documents, according
to a congressional committees review,
show that taxpayers paid the president's company
at least $1.4 million for Secret Service agents,
stays at Trump properties for his and his family's
protection. The records, by the way, contradict
the repeated claim made by Eric Trump, the
president's son, and the Trump. Org's executive
vice president, that the family's company often
gave the Secret Service agents the hotel rooms
at cost or free. Maybe it was sometimes true, but
it often was not. This is the latest grift on you,
the American people. This is, by the way,
sometimes this is used as a way to money
to launder money, which is like the real price of
something is 400 bucks, but you start billing 1200
bucks and then you can launder $800. That's not
apparently what's going on here. Here, it's just
a form of fraud. Listen, the hotel room is worth
400 bucks. We're going to charge the government
1200 bucks a night. We will direct Secret
Service to stay at these rooms and then taxpayers
are going to pay for it. And it is another
complete and total grift. And, of course, oh,
Trump donated his paycheck. Okay. $400,000 a year.
Look at the millions upon millions of dollars. If
you look at all the hotels that were made on
the back of Trump being president, remember,
the other side of this was foreign leaders staying
at Trump properties when they went to D.C. or
elsewhere to ingratiate themselves with Donald
Trump. So it has been a scam after scam after
scam. Extremely profitable, despite Trump's claim.
Oh, I could have made a bunch more money. Trump
made plenty of money while he was president. And
so the fact that he donated his $400,000 salary
really is neither here nor there. Added on to
the list of more investigations that will be done